je vais vous faire goûter 20 chaudière
saucisson il y en avait pour tous les
goûts au 5e salon de mort pas de quoi en
avoir l'eau à la bouche
le salon rassemble et non seulement des
saveurs mais aussi de superbes couleurs
l'occasion pour les exposants de se
faire connaître
voilà l'objectif de ce salon ainsi que
de faire connaître mon produit aux gens
ne mord pas également de proposer ma
bière de noël donc c'est une bière qui
est basée sur une route de flandre
ce salon permet aux yvelinois de
découvrir les différents produits locaux
de la région beaucoup ignorer la
présence d'élevage et de production dans
le département c'était plutôt de la
curiosité cherchait rien en particulier
mais comme je suis dans le coin depuis
quatre ans
c'était une occasion si voilà découvrir
un peu ce qui se passait dans la région
le salon est organisé par la cinquième
fois par l'association lion's club
tous les bénéfices sont intégralement
versés à leurs oeuvres sociales
parmi elles la lutte contre
l'illettrisme à l'aide à l'organisation
de la banque alimentaire et du téléthon
mais pas seulement
nous allons aider aussi l'association
valentin oui pour des financements de
stylos de lecture vocaux numérique
et puis tous les ans on envoie 50 petits
enfants sur une journée récréative des
petits enfants qui ne doivent pas partir
à l'école à en vacances grâce aux gens
qui viennent qui les exposants qui
viennent au salon et ça nous permet de
financer ses oeuvres sociales et les
visiteurs font donc à la fois leurs
courses de noël mais aussi une bonne
action l'année dernière le salon avait
accueilli 1500 personnes